اتمام عقد قران ولي العهد الاردني هو موكب
العرسان سيجوب شوارع عمان اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
من ساعه شهد الاردن والعالم العربي عقد
قران الامير الحسين بن عبد الله الثاني
وكان عقد القران بدا بوصول الملك عبد الله
والملكه رانيا الى قصر زهران لاستقبال
الضيوف ومن بعدها وصل الامير الحسين لقصر
زهران وكان لابس الزي العسكري وبعدين وصلت
العروس بفستان زفاف من توقيع الي صعب مسمم
لها خصيصا اقدمها لعريسها شقيق الامير
هاشم وتم بعدين عقد القران اللي اشرف عليه
امام الحضره الهاشميه احمد الخلايله وشهد
على عقد القران الملك عبد الله الثاني
والامير حسن عم الملك عبد الله وذلك بحضور
140 ضيف بما فيهم اعضاء العائله الهاشميه
[تصفيق]
جابر الخواطر شان ابيه وذويه واجداده
الاكابر ومبارك زواجه بكريمه الاصل زوجتك
[تصفيق]
ومن دقائق صدرت الاراده الملكيه بالانعام
على رجوه بنت خالد السيف بلقب صاحبه السمو
الملكي الاميره رجوه الحسين المعظمه هو من
دقائق انطلق او بعد دقائق عفوا مشاهدينا
سينطلق الموكب الاحمر لكل الاردنيين
بينتظروه بفارغ الصبر وهو تقليد ملكي يعني
عريق من تاسيس الدوله بيتكون من 20 سياره
كلاسيكيه حمراء مع عشر دراجات ناريه فيهم
العشرات من عناصر الحرس الملكي اللي
حيرافقوا سياره ولي العهد وعروسته في
مسيره ملكيه من قصر زهران اللي شهد زواج
الجد والاب والحفيد بنتكلم عن الملك
الراحل الحسين والملك عبد الله والان ولي
العهد الحسين بن عبد الله الموكب بعد
دقائق مشاهدينا سيتجه نحو قصر الحسينيه
اللي راح يكون في
الاحتفال الرسمي بالزفاف ونشاهد الان صور
مباشره والالاف الاردنيين وهم في انتظار
الموكب في الشوارع وهم بيحتفلوا طبعا في
هاشتاق والاحتفالات كلها تحت كانت اسم
نفرح بالحسين الحفل حيكون في قصر الحسينيه
وهذا الحفل راح يبدا بمجرد وصول العروسين
بزفه ملكيه ومن بعدها حيتم اصطحاب
العروسين لساحه الاستقبال في القصر
وحترافقهم زفه عسكريه مرورا بتقليد حمله
السيوفه دي يعني واحد من التقاليد
المستخدمه في الاردن وفي زفاف الامراء
تحديدا ايضا مشاهدينا طبعا نحن بنشاهد
الان هذه الاحتفالات شعبيه والاغاني
والاعلام وحتكون في سبع مواقع مختلفه حيمر
عليها
الموكب وطبعا بعدها زي ما قلت مشاهدينا
راح يصلوا الى طبعا قصر الحسينيه هناك في
قصر الحسينيه كمان راح يكون في مشاركه
للفنانين طبعا الفنان الكبير محمد عبده
والفنان الاردني عمر عبد الله في الزفه
راح يقدموا اغنيه مشتركه للزفه بتمثل
الثقافتين السعوديه
والاردنيه عند دخول
العروسين وهذه حتكون الزفه طبعا احنا قبل
دقائق مشاهدينا كمان شاهدنا مراسم عقد
القران شاهدنا توافد الضيوف اولا بعدين
عقد القران بعدين جهدنا العريس والعروسه
طلعوا ووقفوا وسلموا على الضيوف طبعا كل
الضيوف اللي حضروا الزواج وخلينا تحديدا
بنتكلم نحن طبعا من اكثر من 70 دوله طبعا
كان في من الاسره الهاشميه كان في من اسره
العروسه طبعا الاميره رجوى خلينا نرجع
لموضوع المدعوين تحديدا مشاهدينا احنا اذا
بنتكلم الان عن بالنسبه للضيوف اللي كانوا
مدعوين لحضور حفل الزفاف نحن زي ما ذكرت
مشاهدينا اكثر من 70 دوله بينهم طبعا ملوك
امراء اعضاء عائلات حاكمه رؤساء مسؤولين
الحفل مدعو عليه حيكون 1700 ضيف من بينهم
طبعا من اللي حضروا ايضا كمان شفناهم في
عقد القران ولي عهد ابو ظبي ولي عهد
البحرين طبعا السيده الاولى للولايات
المتحده جل بايدن كانت ايضا حاضره
هولندا وماليزيا وبلجيكا ولعهد النرويج
وولي عهد الدنمارك وشفنا ايضا امير واميره
ويلز ويليام وكاثرن اللي كانوا وصلوا امس
في الليل الى الاردن وللتذكير كثر
المشاهدين كانت عاشت في الاردن لثلاث
سنوات خلال طفولتها ودخلت حضانه في الاردن
وصور من وصول الثنائي تزاولها طبعا
الاردنيين بشكل واسع وكمان صور من تواجدهم
في مطعم احد الفنادق في عمان ليلا
حقيقه الاهتمام بالزفاف الملكي مالي
الدنيا وكل العناوين والهاشتاقات اللي
بتتكلم عن الزفاف ترند من امس على المنصات
وتصميم نفرح بالحسين زين كل مكان في
الاردن وكمان انختم على كل جوازات اللي
داخلين الى الاردن ومو بس كده لا كمان
شفنا فيديوهات لحلويات
وزعوها على المسافرين على الخطوط الاردنيه
الخطوط الملكيه طبعا الاردنيه مكتوب عليها
نفرح بالحسين امس وحتى الطيارات الملكيه
الاردنيه كمان تزينت بتصميم نفرح بالحسين
وبصور العروسين بهذه المناسبه وتم توزيع
الحلويات على
الركاب طيب من بين كمان الاشياء الكثير من
الناس مهتمين انه يعرفوا اكثر عنها طبعا
الاميره رجوى خلينا نتكلم عن الاميره رجوى
هي من مواليد الرياض من مواليد سنه 94
والدها هو خالد بن مساعد بن بن عبد العزيز
السيف والدتها هي عزه بنت نايف بن عبد
العزيز احمد السديري وهي الشقيقه الصغرى
لفيصل ونايف ودانا وال سيف بتعود اصولهم
لمنطقه سدير وهي منطقه تاريخيه في نجد وسط
السعوديه رجوه حاصله على بكالوريوس في
الهندسه المعماريه من جامعه سيركلز في
نيويورك وبتحمل درجه تخصص مهني في
الاتصالات المرئيه من معهد الازياء
للتصميم والتجاره في امريكا رجوى بتتكلم
اللغتين الانجليزيه والفرنسيه ومن هوايتها
الرسم وركوب الخيل وانتشر للاميره رجوى
على الانترنت صور من طفولتها تم تداولها
بشكل واسع خلينا نشوفها
امس كان في كمان مادبه عشاء بدعوه من
الملك عبد الله الثاني لاربعه الاف شخص من
الاردنيين في مضارب بني هاشم اسمها الاجره
وهي بيعملوها اهل العريس وتخللتها عروض
تراثيه شملت كل اطياف المجتمع الاردني
والقى الملك عبدالله كلمه كانت مؤثره
للحضور والوليه العهد اللي كان لابس زي
التراث الاردني القديم مع الشماغ الاحمر
خلينا كمان والملك ايضا نذكر مشاهدينا ان
الملك اهدى الامير الحسين سيف من التراث
الاردني العريق واهدى الحاضرين مسبحه
مكتوب عليها وجعلنا بينكم موده ورحمه
موصوله بقطعه معدنيه عليها اسم الامير
الحسين
وزوجه الاميره رجوى
وكانت امانه عمان اعلنت عن استكمال كل
الاستعدادات للفرح من تزيين الشوارع
وتعبيد للطرقات وتجهيز الاماكن اللي رح
يوقفوا فيها الناس علشان يتفرجوا على موكب
الازفاف اللي هو طبعا الموكب الملكي
الاحمر اللي تكلمت عنه مفصلا في هذه
الحلقه وحتى في حلقتنا يوم امس
مشاهدينا خلينا نذهب لهذه الصور المباشره
الان وبنشوف تحديدا الان امامنا انطلاق
موكب الامير الحسين
والاميره رجوى الان بعد اتمام يعني مراسم
عقد القران بنشوفهم الان في الموكب
بيتجولوا في شوارع الاردن راح يمروا على
سبعه اماكن او مناطق وتحديدا اصلا في الاف
الاردنيين متجمعين بانتظار هذه اللحظات
ومنتظار تحيه العريس
والعروسه طبعا هذا الموكب من التقاليد
الملكيه وهم الان بيتجهوا من قصر زهران
حيث تم عقد القران الى قصر الحسينيه اللي
حيشهد الحفل الكبير اللي مدعو عليه 17
مدعو طبعا الان الموكب في العلي العلم
العلم الاردني طبعا
محيطه بالسيارات
والسيارات الحمراء اللي هي قلنا انها
حتكون عشرين سياره كلاسيكيه وهي طبعا جزء
من الموكب الاحمر انه هذه السيارات اللي
هي كلاسيكيه القديمه وسياره العروسين اللي
هي عامله كانه النجمه الموجوده في العالم
اذا الان مشاهدينا نشاهد العريس والعروسه
ولي عهد الاردن الامير الحسين بن عبد الله
مع زوجه الاميره رجوى الحسين طبعا قبل
دقائق او يعني اقل من ساعه صدرت الاراده
الملكيه
وتم اعطائها اللقب او تم منحه لقب
الاميره وصاحبه السم و الملكي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طبعا اجواء احتفاليه كبيره
الاحتفال هذا كله
يعني هذا كل الاحتفال كله كان تحت عنوان
نفرح بالحسين صار لنا تقريبا ايام او
اسابيع وبدات معالم هذه الاحتفال تتشكل
صارت هاشتاق نشط بشكل يومي طبعا على مواقع
التواصل وطبعا تزينت كل الاردن بهذا
الاشعار اللي هو طبعا نفرح بالحسين الف
مبروك
للعروسين هذه مشاهد مباشره من الاحتفال
وموكب العروسين
[موسيقى]
اهلا من جديد موعدنا الان مشاهدينا مع
الفقره الاسبوعيه 25 سؤال ضيفنا فيها لهذا
الاسبوع النجم احمد داوود انا اترككم
معاها واعود القيكم الاحد في حلقه جديده
من تفاعلكم في امان الله
احمد داود 25 سؤال لازم تجاوب عليهم بسرعه
من غير تفكير ايش الدور اللي من بعده
الناس بدات تعرفك في الشارع
هل صحيح انك بتخاف من افلام الرعب طب اعمل
لنا فيلم رعب ليه هو يعني اثاره وتشويق
شويه وبيخض كده كم خضه وانا كنت بتخض زي
الناس يعني بصوت حلو هل فهدتك دراسه
الهندسه في التمثيل كيف هي بتفيد اي شغل
في اي حته بتخليك تبصي على الحاجات من فوق
مش جواها يعني ترتبي حياتك بشكل افضل
بتشوفي المشكله بشكل احسن اديتك السينس
بتاع المهندس ده حلو هل احمد داوود نجم صف
اول بقيه الحمد لله
في يوم 13 في بطوله مطلقه معك نجوم تانيين
اكيد لكنه فيلم لاحمد داوود هل
تاخرت مطلقه خالص كان في اول حاجه خالص
على عشرين عشره كان في ولد وبنت بس انا ما
كانش ينفع اصدقها وقتها وبعدين كان في
1920 وده ثالث حاجه يوم 13 انت
عاش اللي هي ليه بتعمل في لا مش خاطره
خالص هي خطره بس وانت تتعلميها لكن بعد
كده دي كومبو كده بس لما انت كده فوق طالع
دي جميله ده
ايوه طبعا بس انا بدعي كده
ويهرب بص كده على الميه وربنا بيستر
وبعدين في الاخر بتوقع في الميه مش فانا
يعني
اكتر منه كمان رياضي يعني هو كده كده
رياضه بيشد الجسم بس كمان انت بتمشي على
خشبه متر في البحر لوحدك شمس جبل ما فيش
حد خالص ما فيش صوت موتور فبتخرجي حابه كل
الناس يعني
خمس دقائق وترجع
[ضحك]
يعني شويه شغل كده ثاني ببقى محتاج لازم
مدمن كده اروح اعمل كود ايش السر اللي
مخليك فنان بعيد عن الشائعات يعني ما
بنسمع عنك شائعات تقريبا ابدا اه والله
الحمد لله بس في مره واحده بس اشعه طلعت
كده برده كانت لها علاقه بقى يمكن قالوا
ان انا اعيش في الجونه
فانا لا
كم من عشره لو قارناه بصوتس الاجنبي لا
يعني في مصر والحمد لله ونجح كتير قوي نجح
كبير قوي بس كم من عشره بالظبط بالنسبه
لصوت الاجنبي في مصر
شايف الاجنبي مش كتير شفت كم حلقه بس كده
وبعدين ما خليت يعني جوه دماغي وانا بعمل
سوتس بالعربي ما اهتمتش بالاجنبي خالص
وحبيت ان انا اخلق شخصيه جديده خالص
بتاعتنا يعني تقدر تعمل مقارنه
اوكي ايش احلى شيء في علا كل حاجه واحد بس
لازم كده اساسا
اقرب ادوارك لقلبك
ممكن اقول لك كذا واحد ولا واحد بس يعني
يفضل واحد اثنين مش بس عشان دي اول حاجه
في الدنيا سجن الناس اغير حياتي 120 يوم
13 ههه يلا ولاد رزق وهيبته
طيب بسكويت
انك بتحشي
برافو معلم يا احمد
مش عارف والله بس لا ما قلتش كده على حاجه
بس في حاجات كانت يعني لما الناس بتقول
كده بتبسط اكتر بس انا انا اقول على كده
لا
مشهد احد قال لك عليه كده لا في سجن كتير
وفي جراند كتير وفي هذا المساء في مشاكل
كتير اهو ده اللي صار في مشاهد كتير
ولاد رزق يعني الحمد لله حظي حلو عندي
مشاريع كبيره يعني بيبقى فيها مشاهد صعبه
والحمد لله ربنا بيوفقني فيها طيب صفه صفه
فيك انت نفسك اولادك ادم وجميله ما
يورثوها ابدا
والتوتر يعني اول ما بيحصل حاجه بتلاقيني
كده ايه بنهار ولازم امسك نفسي فبحاول
اشتغل عليها يعني اغرب سؤالا سالته في
مجابله
اغرب سؤال لا مش فاكر بصراحه
لو سالنا علا ايش احسن شيء فيك تتوقع ايش
تقول
ريحتي حلوه لا هي قالت كده مره يعني
مستعجبتني ههه
دي حاجه عشان فقلت اقولها لكن ايه انا
يعني كبني ادم يعني مش عارف لا هي تسالوها
بقى لما تيجي ان شاء الله ان شاء الله
بتحب تتقاعد
بعد ما اخلص كل حاجه في الجونه وساعتها
بقى يقولوا ان انا عايش في الجونه
كده اروح البحر اتمشى اخذ القائد بتاعتي
العب شويه لان انا دلوقتي لما بشوف ناس
كبار في السن بيعملوها ببقى عايز اقول له
الله يعني مش عايز مساعده يا حاج
هل فعلا كنت بطل مصر في الكونغ فو اه
سنتين طب هيكون عيب لو قلت لك مبين عليك
ما هي ما هي مش مكنتش انا بكسب اسمها ايه
بالقوه قد ما كنت بكسب بالمخ يعني كنت اكس
ايوه طبعا ما هو انت في الاخر بتلعبي نفس
الميزان بتاعك يعني انا لو جسم صغير بلاقي
واحد برده جسمي صغير
مش في المطلق يعني انا في الميزاني بس
فكنت بكسب بالمخ اكتر يعني كنت بستنى
واكسب بس كده النشاط كنت
اكبر منك مش ضروري هتفوز يعني
ولا بالمخ ولا بالعضلات
بس لو في سني كده او في وزني ممكن يعني اه
ان شاء الله نتفاهم يعني اعطيني اسم واحد
لفنان من الجيل الحالي انت بتعتبر نفسك من
الفانز
اوكي سر الزواج الناجح
التنازل
والتفاهم شفت انا قلت ايه الاول التنازل
عشان انت لازم تيجي على نفسك شويه في
حاجات وفي نفس الوقت لازم تبقى متفاهمها
من الناحيه التانيه حاجات ايه ده انا بقول
كلام عميق والله
لذيذ ممتاز ايش كان شعورك لما انجريت
منشات ايرادات فيلم يوم 13 تتخطى ايرادات
فيلم هارلي لمحمد رمضان
انبسطت ان هو اول فيلم بغض النظر عن
الافلام التانيه يعني اتبسطت ان هو من
اليوم السادس لحد النهارده هو اكتر فيلم
بيجيب ايرادات في السينما دي حاجه بتفرح
قوي لان دي ما فيهاش مفيهاش اسمها ايه
يعني كلام هي بتبقى ارقام دي حاجه بتفرح
بجد واكثر حاجه بتسعدني اكتشفتها في
الدنيا انك تعمل فيلم في السينما ويجيب
ايرادات يعني فاكر كمان وقت 122 لما كنت
رحت اول يوم السينما بالصدفه وشفت السينما
كلها مليانه الناس بداوا يوروني قاعه في
الثانيه في الثالثه لا احساس عمري ما
انساك اكتر حاجه بتفرح في الدنيا الحمد
لله ما بتحبه حتى لو نجح والناس حبته
[موسيقى]
بتعمل الحاجات خطيره يعني ما افتكرش ان
لسه في دور طلع امكانيات عقلك ممثله لحد
النهارده بس طبعا في السينما انا بحبه جدا
جدا يعني جدا يعني عندها حركه بعينيها كده
كانت بتعملها يعني وفي تامر شويه برضه كان
في حاجات لذيذه بس امكانياتك كممثله لسه
شخصين مشهورين ما بتعرفهم شخصيا ونفسك
تعزمهم على العشاء عايشين او ميتين
المصريين ولا اي احد حتى لو اجنبي ماشي
اول حاجه هقول لك دانيال تخير ممتاز
والثاني حاجه ليوناردو دي كابري بحبه
ثقيله يعني لازم تعزمني على العشره
عشان نتكلم مع بعض كده
هقول لك لا اعرفهم شويه بس احب برضه اتعشى
كريم عبد العزيز
شخصيه تانيه ممكن اقول منى زكي اعرفهم بس
يعني احب اتعشى معاهم لا خيارات برضو
ممتازه طيب لو عرض عليك الان فيلم بطوله
ثنائيه وطلب منك انك تختار البطل او
البطله اللي جنبك مين تختار لا بصراحه
بتوتر قوي من السؤال ده
عمري يعني حتى لو جاتلي حاجه في حاجه غلط
في المعادله دايما دي حاجات المخرج ممكن
اقول رايي رايك بس انا بحس انه لا طبعا
ناس كتير ناس كتيره جدا لسه ما اشتغلتش كل
ما اشتغلتش معاهم لسه نفسي اشتغل معاهم
حتى لو انت بتسمعي انهو كلام وحش قوي حتى
لو هم مش هيبقى زي ما انت في خيالك بس ايه
الفكره ان ده اللي بيعمل اختلاف انك انت
تروح لحتى انت مش مطمن لها او ما تعرفهاش
مين مين مثلا مين كبار ما اشتغلتش عمري مع
كريم عبد العزيز احب جدا اوكي انت اهلاوي
اهلاوي اه بس مش متعصب خالص الاهلاويه
بيقولوا عليا انت مش اهلاوي مش مشكله
سؤالنا ايش احنا شايف الزمالك
[ضحك]
يا رب ما يزعلوش
ههه شكرا جدا شكرا جدا
والله لذيذه جدا